Alice Creek might be playing the witch
in Gretel in Hansel but the horror
tinged reimagining of the classic fairy
tale isn't the first time that the
veteran actress has played an iconic
vadi in 1996 Krieg appeared in Star Trek
first contact as the villainous board
Queen a role she reprised in Star Trek
Voyager and a couple of spin-off
projects with the board playing a
significant role in jean-luc Picard's
latest adventures in the CBS all access
series Star Trek Picard we thought it'd
be interesting to ask Krieg about her
time as the former Starfleet captain's
arch-nemesis while talking with looper
about her role in Grendel and Hansel
Creek shared her thoughts on what it
takes to bring a memorable villain to
life saying I'm interested in what it is
to be human and to be alive your job as
an actor is to try to bring the
humaneness the frailty the bit that we
all recognize however when it came to
playing Star Trek's board Queen finding
the humanity in the character presented
some difficulties since as Krieg
explained I don't think she is human no
one has told me this this is what I have
come to myself but I think she was an
entity that happened at the moment of
creation and she's always been that way
and she always will be and it is
entirely abnormal human we used to be
exactly like them flawed weak far Ganic
in addition when it comes to
larger-than-life roles like the Borg
Queen or Grendel in Hansel's which Creek
noted that it can make the task of
grounding those characters particularly
challenging saying you are allowed to
live life through those characters as
large as it is to possibly write it
their archetypes somehow they
crystallize or distill the human
condition
it's about catharsis about the insoluble
problem of being human on the other hand
villainous parts do provide Krieg with a
sense of freedom as the actress revealed
to looper with other roles you'd need to
try and be just like someone you'd meet
in the street you're not going to meet
the witch or the bored queen in the
street so every now and then to be given
the chance to live in the magic forest
is wonderful because it crystallizes on
certain levels what we all face as human
beings in a very very bold in-your-face
kind of way but even though Krieg seems
to have a good handle on her dark
characters playing villains still can
take a severe mental toll as an actress
Krieg has to live inside her character's
heads for weeks or sometimes even months
when she's playing characters like the
witch and the board Queen that
not necessarily a nice place to be in
fact Krieg almost didn't accept the role
of the witch in Gretel and Hansel
because she was weary of spending so
much time in the dark
in 2006 creak played a cult leader named
christabella in Silent Hill and it left
quite a mark on her psyche speaking of
her experience on Silent Hill Creek said
I didn't anticipate with christabella
how dark she would be you take something
on and you can't do half measures you
have to go inside that space right and
the last few weeks it was just
christabella mad and burning people it
was a dark space to go to that is why
the darkness lives for demoness in the
bowels of this building hides fighting
the face of an innocent thankfully for
her own well-being the actress has since
emerged from that dark space
thanks to Gretel in Hansel director
Osgood Perkins gentle touch creak felt
totally comfortable inhabiting her
latest villainous role speaking about
Perkins approach creak said I knew that
he would come to the witch without
judgment and that he would illuminate
who she was and what she became with
understanding and compassion Osgood was
always looking at her point of view with
her pain with her compulsion her grief
her shamed her exhaustion ultimately
that human perspective is what helped
separate the witch from the board Queen
in Krieg's mind as the actress noted by
the end of Gretel and Hansel you had a
human being who didn't start off in this
place but who wound up in this place
sometimes we make decisions all alone
and we live with them for the rest of
our lives and that's what happened to
the witch that's a far cry from creaks
take on the nonhuman board Queen looking
back on her iconic Star Trek role creak
said I wouldn't like to spend my life
inside the board Queen but it was a
great adventure to live inside her check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about Star
Trek are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]